a magazine from 1958 has posted 129 ways  to find a husband here are the top tips  number 17 be nice to ugly men because  handsome is as handsome does number 40  is the best stand in a corner and cry  softly because they'll come over and  hotspots wrong whatever you think of the  advice  it is certainly better than the than the  list of advice that our culture would  come up with a modern list of dating  tips for women would sound something  like this number one uh totally neglect  your physical appearance body positivity  means destroying your body on purpose  you go girl number two swear off having  children make sure every every man knows  that if he ends up with you his  bloodline will die with him number three  family life is oppressive and archaic so  divorce devote yourself fully to uh your  employer instead number four the more  bitter and disdainful you are the better  and then finally  um number five you don't need no man so  make sure men know that you don't need